ladies and gentlemen welcome to day two
of GameSpot's live coverage here on the
show floor at e3 2014 the people are
stampeding in and our show is getting
underway with a game that I am super
super excited about had it big
announcement during the Microsoft press
conference a new monster coming to
evolve and joining me our Phil Rob and
Chris Ashton from Turtle Rock Studios
here to talk about the game good morning
guys super excited to have you here I've
been lucky enough to get the chance to
play evolve a few times and coming and
e3 was my number one most anticipated
game so you guys have it playable over
here have you been having a lot of folks
come through how's the response been
pretty much all day so who's coming out
on top mostly because evolve you know
pits for human hunters against one human
player monster who's been coming out
mostly monster hunters how they been
faring no I'm not sure it's kind of goes
both ways it really depends on you know
who's in the game and what they do so
all right well let's talk about that new
monster the kraken debuted during the
microsoft press conference
you know previously we've seen goliath
sort of that big godzilla esque monster
this one bit of a difference sort of
frame bit of a different bit of a
different skillset let's talk about the
Kraken a little bit yeah he's uh so yeah
he's a little bit like skinnier a little
bit leaner okay doesn't have as much
health doesn't have as much armor but
the big thing is he can fly so yeah I
can fly where Goliath is locked to the
ground glass can leap around but the
Kraken can stay in the air and jet
around it so it's not is it a is a glide
or is it like it's in flat flat it's a
little bit squiggly you know like a
squid under the water kind of squirting
around isn't here exactly exactly and so
and so because he's in the air all the
time he's got ranged attacks so he's
he's really a kind of mid to long range
monster as opposed to Goliath he's just
a bruiser cool well we're actually going
to see a match play out now this of
course the hunter dropship
sending them all in now we see three go
ahead and we're gonna see this from the
perspective of one specific hunter right
yeah this is hi it's one of our newest
alts we are also showing four new
hunters so the big thing with evolve is
you get to choose different characters
and different monsters whatever suits
your playstyle best they each have their
own play style their own unique gear so
this is hi he's our salt you can see
he's got a big minigun right there he's
also got a flamethrower which is a lot
of fun so he's he's our shortest ranged
character on there's Kraken right there
early contact with the Kraken
making a getaway and then trapped of
course this one of the huge mechanics
that the hunters try to employ trapping
the monster in that dome in containing
them yep yeah that's the trappers job
Maggie who's in this Maggie Scott
besides the dome she can she's got a pet
Daisy so our first pet and evolve here
and everything yeah yeah and Daisy's
look kind of like a bloodhound she'll
yeah she'll sniff out the monster and
shortcut to and she'll also revive
people if you go down Daisy will come
over kind of like that st. Bernard in
the in the end the car to Lego exact
whiskey or whatever but Daisy so Daisy
herself is like a little monster and
then that's that's the trapper class yes
and so we've got the assault here of
course focused on dealing damage the
flamethrower is a real up-close weapon
the mini guns got a little more space to
it right we are seeing actually these
ranged attacks come in from the Kraken
so give us an idea of what what the
Krakens trying to do now and what
attacks it's using to keep the hunters
at bay well it was trapped in the dome
at stage 1 really at the monsters grow
over time they get bigger and stronger
as they eat wildlife they grow over time
so the monster here really doesn't want
to fight us that stage one and so
trapped in the dome I the best defense
is a good offense so Kraken chose to
fight and try to push the hunters back
and once the dome went down now that now
the monster ran again is going to run
and try to eat some of the wildlife in
the
because these maps it's not just for
hunters in the monster in there there's
a whole ecosystem happening yeah there's
a lot of really nasty critters
particularly in this in this in this new
environment you put more nasty critters
in this one all right basically like
sort of they'll actually look like geez
and then there's dune beetles which are
these sort of big nasty super tanky yeah
in there incite insect tanks and they'll
actually eat the food so in a way
they're sort of competition for the
monster right because the monster needs
that food to stage up and so that's a
matter if you're playing the monster now
the monsters hunting trying to eat and
then staging up makes the monster grow
larger and more powerful right and the
monster gets to spend points on
abilities and choose kind of what
strategy-wise like you know what
abilities they want to invest points in
alright we've got another dome down on
the monster and so you know the Kraken
wants to be at a bit of a remove can it
sort of cling to some rocks or it does
it sort of have to Mansell on top of
them you can climb anything yeah but it
once in combat it can really just stay
in the air as long as it wants well what
if you know what does it have for melee
like last-ditch just getting in there
and kind of well that's tentacle si-wing
and the tentacles around that's the
interesting thing with the Kraken is
that while your wallet while you're
ranged and to be clear like as a player
you can choose to play the Kraken and
and while it's got a lot of ranged
attacks you really often times have to
get in close just to finish the job so
you'll find that you'll fight at a
distance and then when you see a
weakness when you see an opening
somebody who's low on health
then you'll dive in you'll kind of
squirt it in really fast slam down on
top of them and then finish him with
melee yeah and when playing as the
monster it's so you know anytime there's
four hunters like right in the group
that's a disadvantage for you you don't
want you want to you want that
separation you want to
scatter the ranks create a little chaos
and then go for the die because the four
hunters we've got four different classes
oh yes yeah that's a megamouth that's
one of the s the one that phil was
talking about his buddies were there to
get them out of it right yeah if you're
if that's the thing it's it's kind of
you know if you're if you're caught off
alone then you're in you're in big
trouble and so that's one of the that's
when I was when I have played as Goliath
that's one of the things I loved to do
was to know where these big bad wildlife
creatures are and then kind of kite the
hunters by them because then the hunters
are not only engaging the AI wildlife
but then you can engage and I create
even more today that's an awesome
strategy you know we actually saw I saw
some guys doing that yesterday you know
yeah it's because once you know I will
admit I learned that the hard way I just
wandered into a swamp and then all of a
sudden a giant crocodile clamped down on
me and having this death spin and so you
know I read yeah that's that's a real
good way to learn and evolve is to have
that terrible stuff happen to you and
then you just want to do it to other
players right yeah that's part of the
fun right learning learning how to how
to you know how to make your way through
the world ai creates these opportunities
for either team I mean for the monster
it's largely food but as Phil said that
dune beetle will compete with the
monster for food will take away the food
in the environment so and then for the
hunters obviously it's a it it's
oftentimes a threat and there we see
Daisy the trappers pet and Daisy will
like does Daisy sort of always have a
bead on the monster orders does Daisy
have kind of a radius she does have a
range much wider so if the monster gets
too far away Daisy can looser and then
it's up to Maggie to kind of lead her
around to try to pick up the scent again
I just love that cracking animation it
really is that squid like the tentacles
like sort of trailing behind right here
we saw a vortex blast in that and that's
really used to push people around to
push them back so like as cracking you
can use it when some
he's trying to revive somebody who went
down and went in cap state you can push
teammates off of them and try to keep
them and you can also use it to separate
people and yeah so let's talk a minute
about how you win and evolve if you're
the monster you can win by just killing
all the hunters right you can wipe the
team yeah alternatively you can go to
stage three and then take out the
objective which in this case there's a
power relay which is hooked up to this
hydroelectric dam uh-huh and and if that
relay is destroyed then the dam gets
destroyed so the monster can win in one
of two ways
and and the hunters always have to
eliminate them or the hunters only have
that one objective right but it can be
very tricky in this match you know
already going on pretty long I mean
sometimes you get an early stage sort of
the monster like blitzes and can get
people alone while they're not really
geared up yet but these long battles
that go to stage two and Beyond are like
starts to get really really tense and as
the hunters as the hunters get in caps
so what we have we kind of have in
evolve is it winds up being a war of
attrition between the two teams the
damage that the monster takes is largely
permanent so even though as you stage up
your pool of health gets bigger you're
gonna carry that permanent damage with
you always
likewise on the hunters team if you go
in capped and then get revived you have
a strike which which limits your maximum
health so you have a reduced max health
so over time the monster loses some some
permanent permanently loses some health
and the hunters do the same so shorts
the end is kind of like who's gonna run
out first yeah and eat and we see now
that we've got a hunter down because
that dropship counter comes up when a
hunter is takes those three strike in
caps or you know just gets eaten alive
yeah the monster can eat people once
there once they're dead so a monster can
eat them entirely but then the hunters
have a chance it's like a two-minute
timer roughly two to come and respawn so
you know gets to the point where as a
hunter
maybe you're you're hedging your bets a
little bit and trying to hold off until
you have a full team again but then you
know the hunters just get there the
monsters gonna be using that time to
feed and stage up and I
there's all these moments where you have
to make these strategic decisions yeah
there's always a lot of choices to make
and that's one of the fun things about
evolve and it starts off when you've
when you initially start the game you
got to choose which character am I gonna
be what's our team strategy gonna be if
we're hunters what character perk am I
gonna take what monster are we fighting
what species of monster and as the
monster you get to choose where you
spend those points on abilities what am
I going to invest in he's got a Krakens
got a lightning strike he's got banshee
mines which will stay in the ground and
then when hunters get close to activate
and then they'll homed in on them and
then the vortex blasts and an aftershock
which is a radial it's a very powerful
radial blast which is really good at
damaging multiple hunters but you got to
get in close to it and you've got to be
close to that and that's that that's
kind of Krakens weakness where Goliath
is very strong up close yeah
Krakens a little bit weak up close so
it's kind of cool to have an ability
that's really powerful that that kind of
coaxes people into that dangerous
situation makes them take that risk and
then Zac you know maybe it pays off or
maybe you're in even more trouble than
you were before let's talk for a second
about the hunters we there I think it's
important to make the distinction
between character and class because you
have four classes of fun riders and
within each class a couple different
characters who are significantly
different yet have similar sort of
through-line abilities well yeah they
fulfill the same
but yeah the way they the way they do
that it's very different from character
to character so we've got four classes
assault
trapper support and medic and so you're
always gonna have those four classes you
always have a medic represented in the
game if you don't it's a losing scenario
so we decided as the developers that
we're just not gonna let people lose the
game before they start the game right so
these four get rid of you guys I
appreciate that but within that we we
give you your choice of character within
that class so for example medic is not
my favorite class but this is this is
like it for the Kraken is it oh there he
goes oh he's going down in flames that
flamethrower from the assault doing
serious damage sorry let's go back to
the medic right we're talking about yeah
so medic trappers my favorite class but
I do love Lazarus who's a medic because
Lazarus is so different Lazarus once
people die
Lazarus can bring them back doesn't have
to wait that two minutes for that
dropship so it's really really which
could be huge but right now then there's
the other medic who I've played as it
has sort of a healing beam right and
Lazarus does not have that so what
happens is in combat Val can keep people
alive when they're being attacked by the
monster Lazarus can't do anything has to
wait for them to die first before I can
bring them back and that's a risk right
if he can't get there in time or if the
Monster eats him there's no body to
bring back oh that's right yeah the
eating is just like that's a really fun
thing as a monster to do is you know
eating wild life is satisfying like yeah
I got get it's Hardy but then something
something dev out downing the person and
then just eating your buddy yeah
absolutely
oh man all right evolved you guys
showing it off here and it's slated for
release this fall yes yeah October 21st
October 21st uh any chance of like a
demo yes coming out give people a little
taste of how that Monster Hunter dynamic
works I'm not exactly sure I don't know
I know we'll do something might I mean
we've got a beta coming there we go our
talks right we did it tell me about the
beta fill yeah so it'll be on the Xbox
and I'm not exactly sure when it's
coming but it is okay so you know people
will get to you know
try it out early and it's a good chance
for us to like check the servers and
check the initial game balance and stuff
like that when it's out in the wild you
guys been play testing like crazy but
three there's no summers three years
yeah no substitute for life thousands of
people right that that whole data scale
up is guaranteed we'll put it out and
they're they'll figure out a way to
break the game you know it'll maybe
it'll be cool like hey that's cool let's
do more of that or maybe it'll just
flat-out break it and there's a patch
that up all right Phil Chris thank you
guys so much for coming on to show
enough evolve one of my favorites here
at e3 and actually a nominee for
GameSpot's best of e3 2014 and
congratulations I'm gonna try to come
see you guys later as I tell super into
it so thanks for coming awesome awesome
man
folks evolved kicking off our stage show
today with a blast but we've got a whole
slate six hours eight hours eight hours
of live program from this stage and from
our stage two and we're kicking off next
we're coming back next with Kingdom
Hearts 2.5 HD remix but first it's up to
the GameSpot newsroom for the latest
news here from e3